abuse doesn't have to be physical
but if you move my hair
without permission to me
that's
abuse
when you verbally
attack because that to me is what it is
you are determined that the answer that
I gave you is not one you want to hear
you do not recognize me as British
and until I acknowledge that I am not
you are not going to stop
what do I do
what do I do at that point so I become
silent
and I hope she would go away and she
eventually did if you ask me a question
and I give you the answer
then that's that move on to the next
question
but if I give you that answer several
times and you won't accept it then let's
recognize that there's a problem here
all right
I am very clear
I was not given the answer that she
wanted me to give and so we could not
move on and it was when she said ah you
would get there in the end
that proved to me you were determined
to prove that I had no right to British
citizenship now that reminds me of the
the Windrush conversation where 50 60
years on people who were born here
worked here or you know have given so
much
can just be
thrown out
I mean you know it's a difficult
conversation but we're going to have it
institutional racism is what Mandu Reid
said she said this was would do you
agree with that and do you and did it
how does it sit with you the fact that
she resigned but do you think there's a
deeper problem here
so institutional racing racism is a
problem all over
the UK it's in the police it's been
established it's in the fire department
that was established it's even in parts
of the NHS it's a problem
and it's in Buckingham past of the one
person isn't responsible
they need to review their whole
um
policy on equality and race they need to
have a conversation with the people who
say they are affected and I know it's
quite difficult when people say I'm
experiencing racism there's going to be
people all over the place to say no you
know this card this that the other
what are they afraid of why don't you
listen because if we want positive
change the only way that's going to
happen is if we listen and we take
action it's the only way